the omicron variant came fast and
furious and it would seem canadians are
split on how they feel our leaders
reacted a new ipsos poll conducted
exclusively for global news shows only
half of canadians approve of prime
minister trudeau's response provincial
leaders continue to outperform the prime
minister in the eyes of canadians
although recent public safety measures
may have led to a slip quebec premier
francois lego continues to have the
highest approval rating at 66 percent
but has dropped nine points alberta's
jason kenney remains at the back of the
pack with 34 percent as for those
measures to control the spread canadians
are pretty evenly split in thinking they
are either too little too much or just
right
when we started into all of this this
pandemic a couple of years ago almost
there was really this sense that we were
all in it together people were really
following the advice of our political
leadership uh we saw um approval numbers
for the prime minister and for
provincial premiers that were at record
levels we even recorded the premier of
quebec i think 97 which was the highest
i've ever seen for for any politician
and where we find ourselves today is in
a different place
i i think the best way to describe how
people are feeling is not just fatigued
but really
frustrated and we are starting to see
divisions
uh emerge among canadians and that sense
that they were rallying behind our
political leadership has definitely
declined so where we're seeing the most
satisfaction with government performance
and particularly in managing the omicron
version of the virus
is in quebec and british columbia but
those numbers are still way way down
from where they were at the start of the
pandemic where we're seeing problems
emerge or alberta saskatchewan manitoba
in ontario
and those numbers are definitely low now
alberta's been troubled for some time in
terms of managing managing the crisis
but when you take a look at the prime
minister's numbers and the provincial
government's numbers in alberta they're
identical so it's not like the federal
government is perceived to be doing that
much better a job in fact it's doing an
equivalent job to the provincial
government and both are seen as doing an
inadequate job by that by people in the
in the province of alberta yeah what
we're seeing on the more punitive forms
of uh preventing people from from
spreading the virus and by that i mean
lockdowns
people are completely divided on that
question now it varies by region younger
people are especially not happy with
with lockdowns and when you go back to
the start of this crisis we were getting
very very high numbers of canadians who
were saying say for example not this
christmas but the previous christmas
yeah we've got to shut things down and
those numbers were in the 70s and 80s
now it's completely divided it's 50 50.
so again this is the controversy coming
back into things and things are not as
certain as they once were around this
pandemic and the management of it where
you do see really high numbers of
canadians rallying behind a particular
position it's about providing more
funding maybe even emergency funding to
our health care system to be able to
provide access to emergency services and
other types of services to be able to uh
you know get us back on track with
everything from elective surgery through
to dealing with uh dealing with with the
cova crisis so that is the one thing
people in this survey seem to be
rallying behind but everything else is
much more controversial than it was
previously